recording in progress
okay hello everyone welcome to another
wolfram language design review part of
our language completeness and
consistency series
and looks like we have two topics for
today
uh first one looks complicated the
second one famous last words looks
fairly easy
all right manipulating held expressions
okay now we also talked about this
yesterday in connection with compiler
um
and this concept of
a
purely
uh of a what we were calling yesterday
structural did we did we finish on
structural expression or did we do we
have a different name for it at the end
of yesterday
um i should look back
but but either way i think it kind of
concluded that this was not something
that really
disappeared
yeah you disappeared
can you hear me now hello
that's weird um i was just saying i
think i i needed to go back and check
but i'm pretty sure we did settle on
structural expression or something like
that but but we also i think concluded
that it's not something that can exist
in the evaluator
yeah we we decided that structural
expression
will be an unevaluated blob
with respect to the top level so it is
therefore not directly relevant
um
for let me see do i have an lcc yes i do
um
it's not directly relevant
for this but it might be okay so so what
we have here
is um
so i was not part of that this
conversation yesterday but i think that
might be related to the third bullet
point
uh on of those three main major points
of something that we discussed at least
in passing
last time right the symbolic inert
representation of symbolic expressions
yes
i think what we're what we're imagining
is
in compiled code
you can write
for some reason two plus x was our
example thing let me just save this in
the right place
um
i think we had a little section for held
expressions did we not
avery
did we do we have a section here i think
it's called
yeah we have a code transformation
folder
okay so let's say
oh let's just start off with the sw
notes one okay all right so
the concept is in compiled code
this would mean
create a data structure which is an
extra struct
which you can then
manipulate and
the other one of these we had was
structural evaluate is that correct
which is in compiled code
you know within compiled code
compilable code
these are things and then then there's a
structural expression
uh data type also within compilable code
and there's another one to construct
like to compound them together to create
compound expressions from pieces
wait a minute we didn't discuss that
that's just the function construct
that's maybe the function construct so
but that's
i mean there are a whole bunch of
functions like construct and apply and
map and so on that you know right the
need to operate on structures
yeah
where their type signature involves
structural expression and structural
expression out
yeah it's like they're ones with numbers
and numbers out and so on correct
okay
all right so
so we're we're talking ab so well i
guess is this i mean is this an ex is
this a normal expert or is this um yeah
it's just because this is the
expert struct in mc code no more and no
less
and you can do similar things
in compiled code that you can in mc code
if that's helpful etai
right but
i i guess my question is we're talking
about how construct and map will behave
especially so it won't treat it like a
normal expert i don't know there is no
explaining i mean it's second argument
is a list a normal expert it will make
another version with the head threaded
down so applying the function the only
point here it is that that when you
compile construct just like if you
compile i don't know plus and one of its
arguments is a list of integers it will
then generate another structural list of
integers as its output in the compiler
so here this is taking a structural
expression in and generating a
structural expression out
correct
the point is just that this is just it's
the same as in kernel c code you know if
you if you imagine having a construct
function kernel c code you could apply
it and it would make a new expression
but it wouldn't evaluate it and then
basically
okay
um i mean the whole point is the
evaluator has its hands off
the but the whole point is when it is if
it is returned
if a structural expression is returned
how does that look in in okay so
when when there is a okay
if you were to somehow return a
structural expression
well you just write a function that
returns it right so if the return type
is structural expression as opposed to
what what is the what is the what is the
return type when you are going to
destructuralize the structural
expression
does that make any sense
so the thing that we talked about before
was if you have a function that has the
type signature you know where it returns
a structural expression
when that
it'll just come out as an expression a
normal expression and be evaluated right
right exactly
okay so this is something that really
only exists
in the compiler
quote unquote won't ever return to top
level correct
about what level you certainly can well
right but it just comes out as an expert
right so i think
the the only the only thing that that we
talked about
otherwise yesterday was what the
behavior of these functions structural
expression structural evaluate should be
in the top level and we sort of agreed
that structural expression i mean
fundamentally these things can't really
work
but but the idea is that structural
expression maybe should just be hold all
complete
you know which is kind of similar to
what it kind of does in the the
compiler
structural evaluate you know we could
have a version of structural evaluation
that basically evaluates it and then
returns another structural expression
object
um
but
yeah i know i guess the third point is
that we could implement a lot of these
things like we could implement a special
implementation of reverse you know on on
where it applies one level deeper right
but we're not going to so i i don't know
i sort of i'm not sure
how valuable it is to to implement you
know all these i mean it's not hard to
implement structural evaluate but i'm
not sure if it's useful to have it
because then people might want to use it
and it just won't quite
i think it's better to have people if
they want to if they want to turn this
the structural expression without
evaluation they have to wrap the holes
around it or something in there compile
code right right okay so
so then
how to determine
how compiled code
returns structural expressions
and the answer is
you can within the compiled code
compilable code
use
hold inactivate etc
right that's the and that so that the so
the way it would look is it would say
function compile
of blah blah blah
and then it would say hold
of some you know maybe it'll just be
hold i mean that this would be an
example hold on it would probably be
struck
with hold yeah
yeah
well i i i couldn't make this might as
well work yeah this might as well work
there's nothing i mean hold should be
defined to be able to take a structural
expression or return a structural
expression
yeah it's just
hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on
unless it has special behavior
it's going to evaluate its argument so
if i did x equals structural expression
two plus one and then hold of x
i would get back
hold of structural expression two plus
one which is pretty weird
i mean just just hold on you know
no i don't understand that i don't
understand oh my god i guess i guess
you're saying i mean just because
basically if you had something like hold
of uh okay maybe an example be hold of
construct or a hold of uh you know apply
f to these arguments or something like
that right in the top level that would
return something with head apply in this
case it would return something with head
f
yeah for example yeah yeah yeah it's
it's just it's attaching a special
semantic meaning to hold within the
compiler which i don't think we want to
do
okay but we don't want people to have to
that that's a very ugly
in that case we should have
a data type or something that's held
struck you know held expression or some
such other thing that can be the return
type of a compiled function because i
just don't think we want to people you
know having to type construct
you know
hold
i don't even know whether that would
work i mean that that's a symbol
and do i have to wrap that symbol in
structural expression
yes probably yeah you do yeah yeah yeah
okay
of
i mean this is very ugly
it is
well we could make a special function
which is structural
structural hold or something like that
no but
i i understand that but the but the
basic point is
we've also got the issue
of import for example okay import
reading something from a file and i
think it will be useful in some cases to
let's say i don't know it's a
json representation of expression which
would evaluate in the evaluator
okay
now we have the mechanism for import to
return hold of something but i think it
would also be useful for it to be able
to return a structural expression which
whose only purpose in life is to be fed
to compiled code
because you wouldn't really be able to
do anything i think it would also be a
bit strange if
if what you're saying is that when you
feed an expression to compiled code
you know if it happens to have the
wrapper structural expression it'll kind
of take off that wrapper i think that
would be very weird yeah exactly yeah
so
right so so
asking my question
because i don't think i've gotten a
clear-cut answer to it so when we're
saying that map and construct and what
not support structural expression that
just means that inside a function
compile
they
like you would expect it's not that you
could write map of f comma
if you did map of f comma structural
expression of two plus x like that first
input there you'd
end up with structural expression of f
of two plus x i presume
no i don't think so i think it would
change it was atomic
well it would depend what f was if f was
a function
no but i have to be a function
look i think it's like a raw thing i
don't think we should allow people to if
we're well i i'm not sure actually go go
ahead
it is it is it
it is our expression but the point is
when you
suppose you
when you return to the to the evaluator
what you're doing is you're calling
you're calling the down code or the sub
code for compiled code expression and
then that returns a that returns the
structural expression thing but then
because of the way our value works it
just automatically gets evaluated
and we can't prevent that
i i was a little confused but let can we
go through one one other thing which is
we were talking yesterday and maybe we
should bring up the notes for that
um
does anybody know what where are the
notes from yesterday
they're in um
uh
oh i don't think they were not on my
screen christopher had them right that's
why um
okay but but so we were talking about
two string and things like that a two
expression rather and we were discussing
the fact that
there are okay there are
okay look there are sources of
not yet evaluated expressions
okay and we talked about the fact that
two expression is such a source
structural expression is such a source
so that's the input all right so so is
your input cell or
yes exactly right that is correct that's
correct except that the main loop
i mean is is but that that's the
equivalent of two expressions it's
effectively what the main loop is doing
right that so import is another example
uh um template apply as another example
binary serialize
yes
okay so these are all examples
of sources of expressions that aren't
yet evaluated now in two expression we
have the mechanism of being able to have
a third argument where we're saying you
know wrap this head before you return
the expression
so i guess i'm asking more generally
what
um you know another source
okay another source is the compiler
compiled code
can
can
return not yet evaluated
nye
expressions
um
and what we're discussing is what is the
way of just like to expression has a way
of wrapping a hold or something
to protect the thing that was just
created what is the mechanism for
compiled code to do that and is it
something that is said that is within
the compiled code to determine or is it
somehow
in the way that that's called
right i would argue it's probably better
for it to be in the inside the compiled
code because first of all if it wasn't
it's probably going to be relegated to
some obscure
fifth argument or yeah option where it's
just like and so far as the compiler is
working everywhere you'd have to have a
wrapper for everything and it would just
be a big mess
so i agree with you put it inside the
compiled code but the question is how
right so the zeroth way is the thing
with construct above i hate it um
yeah i mean the other question is is
will the will the thing always behold or
hold complete or are there other way
other kinds of rappers that you can
actually have inactive
right but i mean
the point is is
sure although you could if you had a
held thing you could probably inactivate
it and so on
the the question is do we do we need one
construct that basically just puts hold
around it or do we need some more
general concepts i think we need a much
more construct i think i think we need a
a way of saying what to do that is like
the way to expression has let me make
another comment what do we have for
compiled
for
external we have the notion of an
external expression right
do we not
no what is it called the an external
handle
like like when you get in um
you know what i'm talking about where
you have a pointer but wait when you
have a raw pointer that comes back from
a piece of java code or something you
can store that raw pointer in the system
right
you don't get the
not really
the way that works is um
wait sorry are you talking about
j-length are you just talking about how
java works
well i think my point is there aren't
any pointers in java there are okay
preferences
but what it actually is
is that um
j-link sets up a um
a unique reference to it so that when
you when when okay okay
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter the
point that i'm making is this
basically we have
just like
you know an external of external object
okay is a blob my gosh this is
pathetically bad documentation
um you know it's a blob of external
stuff that whose only purpose in life is
to be fed back to the external thing
right
do we agree that that's i mean this
thing has no meaning
correct
correct in our top-level system yeah
yeah so similar to what i was just
saying about the j-link thing yep yep so
what i'm arguing is i can see a
situation in which
you might want to do the following
workflow okay you might want to get a
structural expression from importing
something from a file
and feed it to a compiled function
as a pure
unevaluated expression just as a blob
just as an extra struct thing
okay just like
or similarly you might want a piece of
compiled code
to return a structural expression that
you do not want the evaluator to touch
just want to put it on a shelf and feed
it back to the compiled function again
you're just using the top level as a
storage medium for that blob just like
you can use it as a storage medium for
the external object
right or it's a bit like it's a bit like
these these data structures we have it's
just a
structural expression data structure
yes that's right and what what is the
analogy okay so there are some analogies
here
okay so um
uh
which is interesting so an analogy and
what's the relationship um
there's external object and there's data
structure
and i could imagine um aren't there
things with with um potentially with the
external database kinds of things which
are also are there other things here
that are yeah i mean things coming from
entities
things coming from entity stores
databases etc
are also things which are stored
externally in a non-evaluated form as
but they might be stored as experts we
want people to store things as experts
we don't want the evaluator to mess with
them i mean as i was saying yesterday
the idea of this wdf format that we
talked about a number of years ago one
of its principal ideas was use
expressions as the data structure but
keep the evaluator off it
um our dan is also on our live streams
also pointing out how does it relate to
wstp expressions
good question that's another good source
of not yet evaluated expression by the
way in
wsdp there's a thing called link read
held and link right held which i'm not
sure how super documented they are but
they are attempts to solve this
i mean they're sort of documented but
not totally
okay so that's another example of where
those those are not unuseful actually
right but but so the general pattern
here is
there is an external program that is
using the experstruct but is not using
the evaluator
i i e
well you know think you know there's a
general category
things
using
the extra struct
but not the evaluator
see i mean right now for the last how
many decades we've kind of bundled
together
the notion of the expert struct and the
notion of the evaluator and i think what
we're seeing here and what in a sense
when we're talking about held expression
manipulation we're seeing the unbundling
of the extract in the evaluator is that
a fair characterization
and
i mean so
i think it's important that
compiled code
okay i i claim it's important that any
of these things be able to return a
structural expression
and
expecting that at the top level the
evaluator has nothing useful to say
about structural expressions just like
it has nothing useful to say about
external objects they should return
something wrapped in structural
expression exactly and will you another
question about structural expression
does it prevent lexical substitution
that's a good question if i do with a
good question i know i understand the
issue i understand what how atomic
is structural expression
right and that is going to relate deeply
to the things on this side here
another question is is whether
you know
whether structural expression whether
this structural expression is the same
thing as the compiler thing though yeah
because i think if we have this
well-developed concept of a structural
expression that's you know you pass
around and do all these things with and
then we have this thing in the compiler
called structural expression but you
know
but when you pass it in
like like if the actual compiler if a
function that takes a thing of type
structural expression actually just
takes any expression that's kind of
confusing
well i think it shouldn't i think it
should only take a structural expression
like we need to have okay
we have to have a way of passing
expressions into compiled code maybe
that's purely internal but will we have
to have that okay okay hold on hold on
hold on this is this is the problem you
know
it's like quoting the quote it's like
unwrapping the unwrapper you know
whatever okay so the issue is and i
think here we probably need to have some
sort of diagrams and a little bit of a
more formal
approach to what the heck's going on
because
what you're saying is i have a compiled
function f and
i feed it an expression
and the question is is that expression
coming in i mean that expression is
ultimately coming in as an extract
object is it not
to the compiled code okay
have a look at link right held
that's a bit like do question mark on
that do they don't know if there's any
not an impressive level of gosh question
mark
i've never seen something that has a
message documented but it's not they're
documented there are plenty of those
anything that's marked internal and
docutorius anyway right
so this is a little bit like what you're
talking about except it uses a different
function name and it uses hold
so i view this is not unuseful actually
so wait a minute why is this like okay
link right held
is
making
so it writes expert without the hold
but the hold is there to prevent
evaluation so
what's normally done by making link
right held a hold all or a hold rest
function that's how most functions do
this yeah but the whole point is being
able to pass in
a held object that has has been passed
around without exploding
that's the point without having to do
annoying things with width yeah exactly
exactly yeah yeah sure
okay
so i agree that i mean the main point
here is we need a way to pass around
expressions without evaluation we
already have two such mechanisms hold
and inactivate
and unevaluated
but that's only temporary yeah it's
temporary right but but i mean
that's a similar kind of thing of uh
if it's unevaluated as an appalling hack
no no exactly unevaluated is a
cautionary tale and i'll also argue that
inactivate doesn't fit because that's
actually changing the expression
structure
right it changes the expression
structure and it doesn't actually hold
everything so
here you're right don't hold the atoms
what
you you broke up etai
you go ahead yeah complaining about the
fact the design mistake the arguable
design mistake that inactivate does not
hold the atoms does not inactivate atoms
but i think for it one of its design
goals that's very you know like inactive
integrates and things that's very
desirable yes
okay but but so
what we're what we're understanding is
in
okay so
how to feed stuff
into compiled code for example and we're
saying okay so basically there's the
concept of
auto
you know auto unholding
yes when when okay so this is this is
the idea so arguably
it could almost be an
anti-hold attribute is this completely
crazy okay so here's the idea so the
idea is just like link right held you
could imagine a function f
where you pass it in f of hold one plus
and that somehow what actually gets
passed to f is just is the stripped one
plus one
and that's what you want to have happen
in the compiler i think
in other words you want to be able to
am i
yeah because that's what link right hell
does in other words you've either got
okay
you either pass
to this this is like quoting in a way
this is a bit like a quote function
but it's an antiquate because what it's
doing is it's saying
it's like it's like put do an eval on
the quote
um because what it's saying here is
what you want is that in your compiled
code
you're
okay
we want the ability to
we want a way to transport the um
i won't say grenade but you know some
other uh
sodium or something without um uh
without it exploding after it's brought
in from import
we don't want the evaluator to pour
water on it so to speak and have it
explode
but we want to just feed that thing
directly into compiled code where it
will be you know handled correctly
that's why you're about to say something
sorry right i mean
setting aside the compile code issue i
mean what what you're expressing there
right is that you want a way to automate
replace
of hold of x blank
uh sorry hold of expert
you know hold of x blank goes to f of
unevaluated of x right that's how
you would implement this functionality
now in the function that doesn't know
how to describe the whole oh to say that
again
replace
um
you know hold of one plus one
and then comma
hold of x blank
goes to f of unevaluated of x
right that's how you would pat that's a
way to get
um
well that's happened because f doesn't
have any evaluation rules right yeah so
right if f make f equals
well i mean if if f equals
yeah
if f is something
it's just list or something here
well why does that happen
because there aren't any evaluation
rules give
make it f and do f x blank colon equals
hold of x
and make f
hold
you know hold all or something yeah
right i i get it i i understand what
you're saying i mean these are the sort
of horriblenesses about unevaluated
right i know i know so this is what
we're trying to deal with so you know
what i think we need
and this is where we need to look over
here at what we were discussing before
but the basic point is we need a thing
i'm i'm claiming
we need one thing we definitely need
is a thing that stores extra structs
that can be passed around at the top
level and does not explode at the top
level and can be passed back into for
example okay so here's a here's a um you
know what can you do
with an expert with a structural
expression
so part of the issue is that you know i
think if this thing is really 100
totally inert the only thing you can do
with it is unwrap it
you know what about you what about
export it why not be able to export it
if you can import something and get back
a structural expression why not be able
to export it as well
so i was just gonna say if the only
thing you could do
so the only thing you can do is unwrap
it it's the same as hold complete which
is fine but i mean hold complete maybe
maybe we should just be talking about
things hold on please in export you're
actually going to export expert not
structural expression of experts exactly
it's the same issue as auto unholding
and then if we had a way of reading it
in
then structural expression it's not
inconsistent with what we were talking
about in the compiler either well that's
the point that's the point i'm making
that we need
right now it's a good point i think yeah
i think
um
right but this notion which we are doing
in a hacky way with unevaluated of auto
unholding i mean this is okay so what
are the notions that we've got here one
notion is
the idea of a of an extra struct object
that can exist at top level so as as as
i think rob was pointing out this is
really like
you know this is similar to data
structure
uh
you know you could make this be data
structure of structural expression
whatever and you could actually you know
this is one sort of way of put making a
hook to create this thing
blah blah blah does that make sense why
don't we just make it whole yeah it
could do that yes
but that thing
go ahead
so sorry no go go on no what i'm saying
is a data structure here
is just like in the compiler and this
would be a good thing to bring it out as
a data structure because we could
implement this as a data structure it
would take you know like like an hour
well
yeah and what the advantage of
implementing the data structure is then
you actually could have you could have
things like part work exactly you could
have a limited set of operations work on
it with nobody expecting that the com
the evaluator is going to work on it
right precisely right because well this
is this is like super easy because it
would just use expression
yes i understand
that and then we then we would
what is the most
elaborate data structure here where we
can look at its operations
this joint set is kind of okay well this
has enough okay
they've all got quite a lot of stuff
right but i mean so things like length
we can perfectly well implement you know
we could implement a limit i think this
is a good
stepping stone and then normal would
would get you the expression and it
might evaluate okay well hold on hold on
what we want though for the data
structure version of this we don't just
want
so this is the weird case because we
want if we want normal
of the you know structural expression
data structure
um
that would normally evaluate
but we might want a version of that just
like
uh two expressions so to speak we want a
version that doesn't evaluate so maybe
what that is is data structure
is this
structural expression data structure of
held express expression would be the
natural name
yeah
right and then we could got another one
i think this sounds fine the only the
only issue is i think there is this is
this i'm not sure how compatible this is
with using the same name inside the
compiler yeah right because if the type
is called structural expression you're
passing in something that isn't a
structural expression data structure and
it's working it's useful something is
very weird it's a different thing from
yeah
okay fine then maybe we should just call
it expression
the expression data no that's too good a
word data structure expression or data
expression or
or structural expression data maybe
would be fine
i mean expression data
the expression data would be fine
all right okay but needs another by the
way if you do head or part on this you
would get back another data structure
you know
rat wrapping the head or part
actually you know the obvious name here
which is a little bit grotesque but
would be expression data structure
yeah that that would be fine
well i think it's a little data
structure of expression data structure
sounds a little goofy
well
[Music]
yeah right
what i mean it
it it doesn't absolutely have to have
head data structure i mean it could be
the same sort of thing but i think
it's great
no it should be nice a nice frame i
think it should fit in the data
structure
i agree yes yeah okay i'll implement
this like now
okay all right good right but i think
the name is
the name
yeah i mean all of these are data
structures stack is a data structure
it's not called stack data structures
correct let's call it okay this is crazy
but let's for now call it expression
structure no because then we have
structural expression and expression
structure
what what else would you like to call it
what
why data i think expression data is good
why are you calling why do you want to
call expression data i don't understand
but what that even or expression
handle or reference or i think
expression data is good because what it
is
an expression expression
is something that's evaluated and
expression data is kind of the data
before it's been evaluated
i'm not believing that but go ahead and
change that from that and there's a
certain there's a certain lisp you know
code is data thing that i feel like
that's also violating maybe but yeah
right
um
honestly i think it's just expression is
is i no no no no no no because it's a
type this this is going to be a type an
expression is a good name you don't want
to use expression for this we don't want
to use a good name for this yeah
well from expression
well that means
that oh
what was wrong with expression handle i
think tom had suggested
well it's not really a handle right i
mean there's no nothing about it
although maybe one one question
maybe it is okay a lot of these data
structures have mutable operations right
we'll do this
not all of them
there are immutable ones there's an
immutable
this could do we could be perfectly
immutable operations
hold hold on no no no i no please no no
no oh yeah fine okay if you start
mutating it expressions like this will
get terrible consequences
please so the question is the question
is though is
is is if you have hash tables that
become invalid because you mutated the
thing and the things you thought didn't
no you're absolutely right tom
no no no so i mean the question is it's
okay so you're saying that if we had
let's say a set part operator that this
set part operator you'd run it and you'd
get a new expression out and oh it could
do that sorry xq use me yes but yeah it
it that that's redundant because
expression is immutable
you know what about append what about a
pen would append create a new expression
yeah why not why not why not it should
do
could it modify the existing one or
would that could do it
please that's a disaster it'll be
disastrous
right
not immutable expression that's terrible
sorry
expressions are usually immutable so
exactly exactly
dan livestream is suggesting expression
state i don't know whether that really
works quoted i don't think so because i
think quoted well
you know some of these things are are
sort of foreign
um
actually what about expression content
that's kind of crazy
that makes it sound like it doesn't
include the expression itself it just
contains contents
sorry jose you were saying something
what
just expert
oh that's an interesting idea
i think that's also a good name sorry
i don't think that's that good a name
one
thing one thing that could be confusing
with it is is if we do have a and part
of the reason why we don't just do
expression is because we want to save
that name as a name for the compiler if
we ever had expert and expression that
would be pretty confusing yeah yeah yeah
i think this is a slightly
niche thing i mean a long name doesn't
what about calling it experstruct
if we've got branded names like you know
we've got plenty of blended names like
bloom filters and things here
you know this is the thing we know it as
extract so let's call it experstruct
fine i like it yeah that's that's great
okay
right it will be
okay fine
um
so now the question is
given an extra struct data structure
there then it would be a type in the
compiler called experstruct right
correct correct
and which is different from this the the
structural express correct correct yes
so if you have the operations has an
input type
if you have something that has the input
type expert struct it is expressed
expecting an extra struct data structure
it will not just take a normal
expression or anything like that correct
correctly if you're expecting a
structural expression you can give it an
extra struct but it's not it's going to
show up with head data structure or
whatever yeah yeah right okay correct
okay so now let's look at
um
i'm still confused about auto unholding
and what the generalization of
unevaluated is because there's this
question of if you feed in
a
uh okay so wait a minute this is the
data structure case um
if if you feed in a structural
expression
into a piece of compiled code you want a
way to have the i mean i'm claiming that
perhaps we need an attribute that
basically is an unwrapping attribute
just like
in effect
you know so that's what i'm claiming is
we need a you know do we need
should we have
actually there's another possibility but
i think i think that there's a problem
with this steven this this this
unwrapping attribute would work fine for
stuff that has down code but what about
in down values as soon as you unwrap it
it evaluates
well not if it's a compiled code
no not in compile code hang on what is
the attribute go on that goes on to
the function well okay so
this is this is assuming a down value
situation so i agree this is probably
not a good idea
but
my question is
it would be very nice to be okay given a
compiled function
you know given a function f
whose value is compiled code
you know can we
type in f of structural expression
of blah
where we've got that structural
expression from importing a random piece
of json or something
where we just watched it xxx what's that
and have it show up as xxx yeah have it
show up as one plus one finally
how would we do this
well we could just say
if it's structural expression and you
put another level you put structural
expression of structural expression if
you really want an expression that is
structural expression
what
and the same supposing i wanted to get
in a json file
actually get structural expression there
so you would just put double it's like
quoting the quote
so write
f
double up the structural expression
you mean
okay
so you mean you mean you want with two
levels of it
yes tom is suggesting that if f is a
function that expects a structural
expression it will auto strip one level
so that's exactly right
that's the first one
in the first case f of c one plus one in
the second case f will see structural
expression of one plus one you got it
you got it yes i mean you know you mean
if you needed to feed in an explicit
structural expression
but you would you would but i don't
understand we've got three cases okay i
type in
let's say it isn't one plus one let's
say it doesn't let's say it doesn't have
an evaluation issue let's say the thing
was just you know list one one for
example okay
um
then
what gets passed into the compiled code
so so the data type
of what's coming in would be
a struct let's say in the compiled code
that this is
a function
where it is i'm i'm not sure i know how
to do this properly but typed of x comma
structural expression yeah yeah i mean
you you could write expression now and
that that that would work so
yeah well
do we want
but do is it expression or structural
it's go right now it's expression it
will be structural expression yeah yeah
okay all right okay so then then this
thing here
if i type f of one one
and or if i just feed this
you know function one one okay let's
let's consider this case right then what
goes in there is
it just goes in as a structural
expression it does what it does so for
example here i could type length of x
here
and that would be a compiled you know
assume this is a
function compile
yeah yeah yeah of this
and that would just work and give a
result too
yes get rid of the structural and
evaluate it probably i think it should
work
you'll get it it'll take 10 minutes tom
it'll it'll take literally
i think i think it'll take like 10
seconds
he has to launch my stopwatch
i need my stopwatch
oh yeah i've got a new stopwatch here
okay
what oh i didn't even i i haven't even
had time
do that again sorry it was launching the
compiler do that again
that was much more respectable yes
okay all right so this just works so
that's great
so now the question is
uh to have i mean i'm going to change
that to structural expression just to
see what it would look like
um
let's say this was structural expression
should this just work you are proposing
that it should just work
i don't see an objection to it just
working that would return
too
yes because one plus one plus one and it
would return two
yes that's correct if that was one plus
one it would still return two
i i
i think that's a
bad idea i mean so basically what we're
saying is that
we're saying i mean the question is how
does the compiler process the
expressions coming into it before it you
know runs the code on it and basically
we're saying is that
it doesn't do anything unless it has
head structure
which case it removes one level of
structure
well no but this is the i i look
so i i don't underst
oh right so the point of the structural
expression
the thing is it is like an external
object it came in it is a pure extra
struct thing it is not making use of the
evaluator it is purely structurally an
expression
it is not
uh you know it is not evaluationally
it's an expression
so i think the way you do this is we
just talked about this expert struct
data structure you would just pass in
the extra struct data structure and then
for your type of x you'd say type of x
comma extra struct
okay so wait a minute so so so then then
okay so then you're claiming maybe
import
should be able to return
an extra struct data structure
yeah i would say so i mean actually
that's that's not crazy
instead of
um
that's the alternative to
this notion of a structural expression
in fact that sort of solves your your
hold problem so instead of using hold of
expert in something you just
pass some function an extra struct data
structure and then it can decide how to
evaluate it when it wants to
yeah i mean the extra struct data
structure is deeply uh not an evaluation
story
right and so
i see so then the idea would be we would
be able to say
um
import
of um you know file.wxf
and then the element would be
experstruct
right and then that would return
and if you export it it exports the
unevaluated expression
well you export the data structure if
you're doing this if you say export
um
this is super interesting i want to go
into something
yeah
i think it's going to be great tom i
mean it's easy to implement too yeah
yeah yeah it's really easy it's that
easy okay
all right so then
if we're just going to have the data
structure do we still want to call it
express structure you want to call it
structural expression
we possibly could
i kind of like extra structure it's a
low-level thing yeah yeah that's what we
all call it
yeah and um
i mean it's a little slangy
but um and sanders on the livestream is
is complaining that it sounds mattel
happy
i don't know i don't know that you don't
know what that is
um
the
my standard for these things is um
uh schoonship where the main operation
was where all the mnemonics were in
dutch
and um
i think yep y.i.p was one of those type
theory there's lots of dutch and flemish
type theory people
is that right do they have other other
key words like de bruyne index seasons
it sounds like a dutch or flemish name
so well he was a long time phillips
operative yeah well
he did lots of interesting things
yes
including the system called automath
which was an early
theorem proving thing
the
um
i never met him unfortunately
um
they uh
anyway
um
let's see where were we here so all
right so the export case
what one will be saying is if one wants
to have an unevaluate an un
a not touched by the evaluator
expression structure
then make it an expert struct data
structure that's the basic message here
and
that means potentially some of our
operations on on on unevaluated code
could be done
by simply turning okay so here's a
question
how do you turn
okay so so now we have
create data structure
um
and we want to be able this is again an
auto unholding question right so you
would do extra struct as the first
argument
yeah but then what because i want to i
want to pass an expression i want to
have something that i typed in right
then you would do like part one at the
end of it
the end of what
you you would type that and then at the
end you would that would return a data
structure handle to hold of expert and
then you could strip off the
that is a hack
that is a ridiculous hack you would say
that
that what you're saying
it would work yes i know it would work
but it's a not a good way to do it i
think
i am not sure you'd want to make create
data structure hold rest for this yeah
yeah no you don't you definitely don't
you want to be able to
carry an expression around
in
i mean otherwise
you would not want it to be the case
that this thing just strips off holds or
hold completes or something like that
no but there's something okay look look
it needs a wrapper
okay the basic problem is i want to be
able to type an expression using the
parser
where i'm you know again it's how do i
get an expression that is a not yet
evaluated expression
okay the number one way is use the
parser
right because that gives you an
expression which when first created is
not
um
uh
um
let's see when it's first created it
hasn't been evaluated but you want to
use the parser to type the stuff in so
the question is you know if you could
have a different form of hold that would
be stripped by create data structure or
by look the other possibility is
oh how to do this
you could have an additional argument
that says
that's like an option strip hold
well you could just have a
no it has that it's fair args
yeah
um
okay but the okay the other point by the
way is the extra struct data structure
could have a print form that looks a lot
like the expression that would help for
many purposes
do you see what i'm saying
um
it certainly could
be that would make it unique the other
data structures have a sort of you know
data you know if you look in the
so you don't want it to look like that
i'm suggesting that it says data
structure of and then it actually shows
the expression here
because because we have a way to show an
expression we don't have a way to show
a length 5 000 linked list or something
i mean it can show a a a a
an impressionistic version of the
expression like if the expression is
very long just show dot dots things like
that fine
um
i mean it probably needs some design it
might need to say it might have a little
thing up at the top that says
experstruct and then it would have the
actual expression
and it should probably have the data
structure over wrapper maybe we'll
change our mind about that but okay we
have not solved the problem of how do
you i mean this is the analog of the e
function
in internal code
that creates an expression by using
essentially the parser
but
as a pure extra struct
um i'd argue that there's there's
there's e and there's also apply if you
have because those are the two
kind of
cases you need one of them is the case
where you know
right i mean basically if you have a
fixed if you have a small number of
arguments versus if you have a lot of
arguments
okay
but that
fair enough
yes
but i mean okay so we have an unsolved
problem here which is how to
how to create
an extra struct
well suppose you have an extra struct
containing the symbol f
right maybe you can say
you know maybe you can say of quote
supply
and then i don't know give it a list of
other extra structs and it will apply to
those no why not or give it an extra
struct of a list and it will apply to
that or
there's also a question of the direction
should the apply
should you should the apply operator be
on the f or on the list of experts
yeah well that's i mean yes but this is
where we have to invent a whole sub
language and pretty soon we're inventing
something which is like an expression
manipulation language so i would claim
that the right thing to do
would be um uh okay so i'm gonna make a
claim that we should be able to do
something like this
um
you know where that actually is an
arbitrary expression
that's kind of weird i mean that that
take take that out
and this is some kind of i don't know
what this means but
maybe do a different apply function from
apply
yes
i mean the standard by the way with data
structures that there'd be a comma not
an arrow
yeah yeah yeah
right so what that would do is it would
take this thing and it would insert it
it would spray it into the extra struct
without evaluation
right so if this is extractive of um
it would return a new thing with would
you return a new expresstruck that just
says total yeah yeah yeah
this is great this is great
it's a bit weird to call it a play
function i mean i understand why but
right it's not it's not apply in our
sense it's what is it
actually
applied
no no apply will be something different
apply would be total
total of one two three
it's massive this construct by the way
yeah
yeah it's applied level zero but
now at level zero
yeah
but but but this by the way that's not a
good use of construct like that's bad
you know you'd expect that to work if if
the extra structure contained
total
and you were just say apply function for
the time being but this is
why isn't it apply
because apply would give you this and
what we want is total of one two three
like this
oh i sorry you're thinking of rap you're
it's it's like you're wrapping it yeah
yeah
right so why is that not a good use of
construct
yeah i don't understand why that isn't
exactly construct because because it's
it's sort of backwards i i would expect
that construct you'd have the f you'd
have the function name as an expert
struct you know the head is an extra
structure and then on that you would say
construct and give it its argument
it's as if we had e operating on an
expression which would be just totally
bizarre i mean
i mean e operates with expression
arguments versus operating
with some expression in mind when you
use it
okay anyway this is a we should solve
this but but the i mean
the thing is well let's get this thing
implemented let's get the extra
structure data structure implemented
and start start putting
it even as we speak
um okay and then and then um uh that's
always a good sign with tom when he said
and yeah
uh okay but but but then you know then
feed in just put in a big collection of
random
you know methods functions whatever and
then let's look at what what we can do
with them
but i think we're still
by the way
these things will work in compiled code
as well
just i've worked very hard
so whatever you write here you can write
that in compiled code so no i understand
that understand that although this would
be
in compiled code you could also write
regular
top level code
that
is then compiled
and we'll do these operations yeah i
mean that that's that's some
um
i still think that there's going to be
value
well okay so the question really is
is this our way
of carrying around
a purely structural expression
is this our sole way of doing it an
extra struct
um and it could be
that that's what you get so let's look
at our sources here
okay
so do we believe for example that we
should have just down here um
okay so we believe for example could to
expression
of one plus one
comma
extra struct
that would be a thing we would have to
support
anybody got an objection to that
no no
i i objected that that is
uh right i mean the second argument is a
format type this is another yeah yeah
yeah
right it tells us you know tells you
to follow
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
okay so this is standard form extra
struct
ah okay so use it as a magic string
which it's a short form of data
structure of
expert comma pound well accept that
notice that
see the important point is
that data structure create data
structure
is not hold rest right
so the alternative here would be to have
an actual structural expression thing
that is a wrapper that is equivalent to
create data structure i mean that's
another possibility to have structural
expression be a function that evaluates
to a data structure of an expert struct
wait but now this is
i feel like that's very strange
that's different than how it's using the
compiler so yeah right
so far we have so far these have been
totally
unrelated
wait wait so is structural expression
something that exists in the compiler
already
it's kind of kind of yes
yes and what it is it is something where
it's it does exactly what we're now
talking about which is structural
expression of one plus one
uses the parser effectively to parse the
one plus one but without evaluation and
simply turns this into an extra
structure
because it's already been passed it's in
a function well fair enough
but when you say it turns it into an
extra struct critically you mean it
turns it into
like
it does not turn it into the data
structure extra structure it just turns
it into an expression
type you're you muffled christopher yeah
literally the expressions extra struct
yeah it's
you know binary compatible abi
compatible with the kernel yeah
right but but so again i don't think so
so within compiled code
see i think these are again maybe there
is a worthwhile concept of two
expression
having this is the question we keep on
asking how do you pass if we have
structural expression of one plus one
can appear in compilable code it does
it does nothing as such other than
when the compiler ingests it
it turns that into
the internal
expression structural expression
type
now the question is what if structural
expression were to get released to the
top level well right now we're saying
it's atomic and it does nothing
right
so the only question is well kind of
again what do you mean by if by release
do you mean i have something with type
structural expression i return to the
top level what we're saying right now is
it just it comes out as the expression
one plus one and it will evaluate and
turn into two
yes if it is being released by the
compiler through its normal channels if
i simply copy paste the code
but just it's just hold on
right
and but i argue
okay the on the way out structural
expression is stripped by compiled code
but on the way in we're saying there
isn't a way to strip it so in other
words
okay so compiled code
effectively strips
structural expression on
on on return
on on input
what would happen if you fed you know on
input what does
f of structural expression one plus one
do
i really think it creates a structure it
creates a structural expression in the
compiler with head structural expression
as opposed to with head plus yeah i i
okay but but but i think it is useful
and now we're going to get into an
unevaluated hack
it's useful
to have some way to be passing around
you know you got it from your importing
your json file you've got it from us
deserialized whatever
you have a thing that is a structural
expression at top level
and
now you want to pass it into the
compiler yeah and i mean i'm not
convinced that that just
you know stripping the structural
expression is totally incorrect because
what what happens if you inside of a
compiled function
you write structural expression of one
plus one now that structural expression
is script right so so in if you wanted
to construct a structural expression
with head structural expression you'd
already have to use the double quotient
so why is that inconsistent with
arguments
i mean i think that i agree i i it seems
not crazy to me to have this auto
stripped
i i'm just slightly worried about these
things where it's like
you know we say oh you're passing in any
expression here and you're going to get
the exact expression and you know
if you're doing symbolic manipulation
with it you know it's all it's all going
to be safe but then oh we'll wait whoops
you passed in the one expression that
gets that gets manipulated like i'll
give you an example right one of the
things i was playing around with you
know a while ago was was with um
you know optimizing and closed confirm i
wrote something which which i might have
otherwise written you know kernel c code
which which is sort of a bad idea but
just you know traverses down the
expression finds the confirms replaces
them etc right um
and and so
imagine if i if i wrote this you know if
i wrote this using this then there might
be certain magic expressions with head
structural expression that you could
pass into this function that would end
up getting mangled yeah yeah yeah right
and in particular they would end up
actually evaluating because they would
come in as a structural expression which
is held and then when they get returned
that structural expression would have
been stripped and so they'll suddenly
evaluate in this dangerous way
right i mean this is the thing is i
think if if one of the main applications
of having compiled functions that accept
structural expressions is that you can
do very safe low-level manipulation of
experts
then if if they can sort of get somehow
magically unwrapped that's very scary
um we ran out of time here
but we had a lot of good stuff to
discuss here and we should probably pick
it up um next time
uh
i think this was very useful
um
i'm trying to remember what uh
that remind me what is this
this is
so
this was an idea that
could be just for map or it could be
just or it could be for both map and
replace
of right you want to insert something
and you want to insert it evaluated
but
you know it's inside of a hold so it
wouldn't normally evaluate right so you
have
well just a stupid example right
you have hold of one plus one
and or you know you or you have hold of
a list of one two
and you want to square everything but
still
remember this issue so in a map
the question is
the map
normally so this is very similar to this
issue actually it's a similar issue here
and possibly we could even use the same
mechanism because what you're you're
saying this is the immediate evaluate
mechanism and what you're saying is
map of immediate evaluate
oh of hash squared or something like
this
on
hold
of two
well actually the map no no no just do
hold of two that'll be good enough right
so right that would give you hold of
four as opposed to hold of what if you
did this at least
right because the map is just level one
no no no you're going to be squaring you
you don't want the list
right
oh i want you just you're saying i want
no no just evaluate that no no no list
just do
why why would this work
right by the pure function the two
right so right so just do
pound squared
remove the immediate evaluate and
evaluate that and you'll see what you
get
i know what i get in that case
i mean i get whole squared
no you don't you get hold of
um
right you get those right
so
you want the pure function expanded out
but not to evaluate
no it should give hold of four
right that's what the immediate evaluate
should do yeah
and i guess this is because this is
function of function so
yeah what do you want from this etip
sorry i'm confused
let's not cover this
right well just just the point is that
this would give you hold of four rather
than hold of pure function of two which
is what it currently get getting in
right i claim this is not it it would it
would rather than just inserting the
things at each place it would insert
eval that part
and then
then insert the the evaluated expression
i'll implement that as a method in extra
struct data structure
it's it's pretty trivial so fine
okay but i mean i'm telling you this is
not completely unrelated to this whole
question about passing in structural
expressions
no there there's def there are
definitely connections and we'll need to
continue this some other time
sounds good all right thanks a lot guys
yes everyone
yes
hey tom
sorry to cut in but time do you have
five minutes to join my zoom
yeah sure i can come over
okay
thanks to folks on the